good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's Thursday we this has been a long
week because you know we've been working
super hard getting tons of guests
including today which is the TMT Ex lady
gang crossover that the world has been
waiting for we've had each member of the
lady gang on the toast separately but
not together we actually don't even have
enough microphones for how many people
are gonna be on this stage today but we
will figure it out they will be joining
us later in the show so make sure to
stay tuned for that very excited to chat
with them all together and to see their
dynamic together yes I feel like I know
them all individually even when I lived
there I think that I'm a Pecha or a jack
or a Kelty but I'm interested to see
them be all together even when we did
their podcast Beca was missing so we've
really never seen them all you know
wound up together exactly so it's gonna
be so much fun so much stuff to ask them
zo is here
and not only is he here but if you're
watching live on YouTube well we have we
just moved into our studio only two
months ago we have finally got our Theo
cam together so without further ado the
real star of the show
Theo scam he's dead asleep he had a busy
morning with mom we took a big walk he's
just sleeping his way to the top his
hair is in his face but he's okay with
that he looks like he's hungover so
thank you we're so excited about that I
mean people who you extend people were
like saying that the show isn't the same
without the Theo cam so for that we're
grateful yeah and so like we said every
day the shows getting better and better
bigger and better more guests I feel
like after this week our numbers like
will have doubled because we've had so
many guests from different walks of life
it'll be interesting to assess the
numbers yeah and tomorrow we have Mike
Sorrentino and Lauren Sorrentino which
is very exciting
I'm lots of questions for them about
Jersey sure you know they've been
through a lot so I'm really excited to
talk to them like right we also have a
busy fun exciting day full of fast five
stories we've got TV recap from Real
Housewives of New Jersey because in one
morning oh my god yesterday my longest
day of my life because we had to wake up
so early to join in camera and rerecord
and then I recorded the redheads last
night right starting at like 7:30 but it
was such a long episode we finished at
like 9:00 and then I had
edit it and it will be up at noon today
the new episodes of the new episode of
the redheads it's so good the book was
so cute we all had such different
thoughts on it we talked about what
we're gonna choose for next week next
month other books that we read this
month it's just a really great community
and you also gave it the assignment for
next month right yeah in the episode so
make sure you're subscribed to the
redheads follow us on Instagram it's
it's never too late to join the book
club and today is like the earliest you
can get in on next month's book so great
today would be a great place for you to
start isn't it weird when we refer to
Lauren and Cameron from love is blind
like my mind always goes to Lauren
Elizabeth and camera and her boyfriend
yeah and it's just so weird that there's
like a couple out there with the same
names it is weird I don't think I
actually I do n't know another Ben oh no
no sorry uh when I went to a wedding in
Mexico there was somebody staying at the
hotel who was a part of the wedding
whose name was Ben saw her but spelled
SOF ER and Ben got to the wedding very
late and we were already at the Shabbat
dinner and they gave they gave Ben's
offer a key to his room because he got
he took a separate flight from everyone
and he walked into the room gotten as
you heard and then it got out of the
shower and he saw like he knows what my
makeup looks like like I have all these
pouches they have my names on it he saw
like they're an older couple so he just
saw like different things and he looked
at the suit like this is not my stuff
and he literally ran out but I could see
how I can see how it would be confusing
there were two two rooms at the same
hotel
Benjamin suffer and the only difference
was that one of them had one F and one
of them had no that's an impossible
situation yet so this Shabbat dinner
he's like sofa Clemson he's like telling
everyone that he was in Benjamin and
mirus offers room and it was like so
much drama at the wedding been like
started this whole thing that is
actually so crazy I don't know another
Jackie and Zach right that's what I'm
sorry that's what I was saying yeah I
don't know another Claudia inventin I
think you know what I don't want to I
think the one is enough I think if I
made friends in my old age that were
named Claudia and Ben it just wouldn't
work also it was just honestly like I
would be offended like that's weird I
only have space in my life for one I
totally agree
okay well let's get into the Fast Five
stories because be much to discuss I had
to watch Real Housewives of New Jersey
this morning while I did my makeup
because I was so backed up yesterday oh
I made sure like tea
he has become like homework for us and
it's a factor like in my social life
like I cannot get home too late the
latest I can get home on a weeknight is
10 o'clock because I have to watch 45
minutes without commercials of something
on Bravo at least sometimes it's two
things so it's really like become a part
of my like my way of thinking like when
it comes to planning my life me too
it's but it was a great episode even
though the looks were not on point like
I would have to say this might have been
one of the most poorly dressed reunions
like I liked Jackie's dress and I liked
Margaret's dress and I think that's it I
like Jennifer's look oh I did not like
it was it a lot you know what she wears
like the guys Oh like literally like
Chanel Chanel and her dress literally
looked like Giovanni wannabe bomb on oh
I liked it I thought she looked so good
even when they were flashing back to
this season she looks so different on
the reunion well yeah because she's been
getting more work done literal new Fox
yeah I respect I absolutely must go to
be late in I know I feel like there was
a lot of like people like you know
looking down on when she was like I got
my liposuction my back and a tummy tuck
and I actually really respect anyone
who's like super open and upfront with
the work that they get done and I think
it actually sets a weirdly like a good
example because everyone's doing it
anyway especially if you're on TV so the
least we can do is be honest about it so
people who are naturally who aren't
doing it don't feel like right we are
just a pressure like that yeah like how
come my lips don't grow on right and
Jennifer like just don't just defy
gravity I love when Marta was talking
about her boobs but but Jennifer also
like lost 25 pounds and then got the
tummy tuck and then the little
liposuction in her back so like I feel
like she's rewarding her hard work I
really respected it and even though like
after the reunion last night like I
absolutely hate Jennifer I still really
like respected her her openness on that
topic yeah and on the topic of her
brother that there's a lot that I really
like about her we'll get to it she was
being an animal someone once called me
like the CEO of we'll get to it yeah
because I'm always like jumping no but
that's literally me and that's me on the
redheads I am a teacher like someone
will be like and the moral of the story
I'm like we'll get to it do you think in
another life like you could have been a
teacher yeah I think about it all the
time on the one hand I would want to be
a teacher because I love the movie bad
teacher and I would just eat in front of
the students when they haven't had lunch
yet
yeah and that would make me feel
powerful that's so mean but then on the
other hand it's like no
in filth and kids yeah I don't know with
I think a substitute teacher well Holly
Holliday yeah I think that's where I
might shine by the way remind me to
bring up Holly Holliday to Becca Tobin
when we talk to her later and we Roz
Washington because she was just on the
lady gangs yes she was just on the lady
8-round Washington um back to the
teacher thing I also think about being a
teacher in two ways the first way is
that I absolutely hated school every
minute of it like I hated it with a
burning passion like I just was not
meant to be schooled high school college
middle school like all of it I
absolutely hated everyone around me I
can't imagine having a job that put me
back in that like bad headspace yeah and
that toxic ignited but I hated school so
much and I really [ __ ] hated my
teachers so I feel like maybe going back
as a teacher would be full circle it's
like going back to campus accounts or
like you're in charge now you think the
world's like I could actually make a
difference and not be an [ __ ] right
right all of the wrong so I think in a
lot of ways maybe I might my disdain for
school and the whole academic system
would actually make me an amazing
teacher but again I've made it as a
podcaster so I'm not going back yeah but
I do think like we are teachers in some
ways I think I actually have to like hot
of a temper to be a teacher like [ __ ]
yeah I have such a short fuse I really
say like really evil things when I get
heated and you just can't do that [ __ ]
to children in order to be a teacher it
scares them for life like health they'll
write their college essay about the
teacher who snapped on that excuse me
I'm a teacher threw a chair at me once
well like next to me but still it was he
got really heated and it was really
inappropriate and I never forgot it and
like I would be throwing chairs pencils
like I would be throwing [ __ ] all around
the classroom so like I see how it
impacted me as a young child that I
could I would really be scarring in the
next generation I think you're doing
what you're meant to do oh for sure what
are they gonna call the generation after
Jenny well we're starting at you then I
hope that if we both thought it yeah for
sure then it means nothing
okay without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you and Theo
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and
today couldn't be a more perfect day
because our episode is brought to you by
oli and Theo's here his Theo cam is
working and Ollie is everything that you
need your dog's health is as important
as every other member of your family and
it's star
with what you feed them but do you know
what's in your dog food Olli puts dogs
first with vet formulated recipes and
fully transparent ingredients to give
your dog the healthiest food possible
Olli makes fresh meals for dogs with
real ingredients that people can eat and
deliver them to you on a regular
schedule they beat out store-bought dog
food at ten to one on the pail ability
scale because they created customized
vet formulated recipes made with
all-natural ingredients no preservatives
and source from us Farms go to my Olli
calm answer a few questions about your
dog
and they'll customize recipes to your
dog and ship pre-portioned meals so your
pup gets the perfect portion every time
they've delivered five million meals and
Counting shipping is free and if your
dog doesn't like the meals they have a
money-back guarantee well Theo's never
met a meal he didn't like so it doesn't
matter what I feed him so like I need to
just be feeding him the absolute best
and ever since I got the Oh from his
first vet appointment his dad has been
telling him to to eat Olli and he's been
on it now for like six months and not to
be gross but like his stool is perfect
like he is just he's perfect and he like
he would eat anything so he obviously
loves it but I love it yeah it's like he
gives you peace of mind knowing that you
are giving your dog the best of the best
and I'm on a mission to like Cavaliers
really typically because they've
congenital heart failure only live about
10 years so having them be overweight is
like the worst thing you could do for
their heart so that's why I'm like so
nuts about like keeping Theo just like
healthy and and trim and slim and slim
because you could really add years to
their lives by doing that so that's what
all he's doing that's why he must be the
snatchler and today's Theo cam is
actually brought to you by Ollie yeah so
Ollie's offering our listeners 50% off
your first box plus a free bag of treats
at my Ollie calm slash toast
so my oli accom slash tries slash toast
my Ollie calm slash try slash toast this
is the best deal they have available
anywhere go to my oli e.com slash try
slash toast for 50% off plus a free bag
of treats spelled my o el Liu comm slash
try slash toast check it out sign on get
your dog to be the spatula
it's hard man we love a perfect stool
here at the morning toast okay I
actually like have never had a perfect
storm really
in my life I'm sure that you know I'm
telling you that I haven't except
sometimes when I'm hungover they're
they're closer to perfect but okay I'm
gonna just pivot here because our first
story is so exciting
Katy Perry is pregnant the singer
reveals she's expecting her first child
with fiance Orlando Bloom in a new video
for her new song called never worn white
and it's [ __ ] beautiful it's a really
good song I feel like the idea that's
beautiful
Jackie keeps quoting my comedy special
and it's like really honestly flattering
I love it I like oh it just is stuck in
my head no I now pronounce things like
regular words but I pronounced it weird
on stage because I was like trying to be
funny or like the word was intentional
and I now say words differently yeah
when you de though but exactly has
something that I want I'm like oh is
that aqua for if so may I borrow yes
Jackie that's really good I can't wait
for everyone to get these jokes yeah
well for the people who have seen your
show they might get it but you like from
show images but we've seen the show 75
thousand excited for everyone to see
your special seventy five thousand times
so that like we can all be in on these I
don't ever really state yet but I'm
trying to do it for April so just stay
tuned I will let you know as soon as
it's ready the editing is done like I've
edited um well I didn't edit it but like
I gave my notes and I yeah like I just
got the final mix down of like the color
the audio and it looks like not my mix
down by the way I mix sound makes a huge
difference like the special is that kind
of great before they mix sound now it's
like [ __ ] saturated that's how like
it looks so Tanis Guinea it's amazing
love it well I'm so happy for Katy Perry
have you listened to the song I did and
I watched a music video because I saw
like Twitter she's pregnant so a bunch
of Instagram like looking for the
announcement and it wasn't there and
that's where people typically announce
and then I was like she just keeps
turning this music video and then I
realized that the announcement was in
the music video which was great
marketing and it forced me to watch it
yes this song is like one of those great
songs where it's just like explains you
know in plain English how she's feeling
yeah right I had people try to make me
like a read between the lines yeah I
guess the only thing I was had to read
between lines is like she's never worn
white meaning she's never been married
yeah and she talks about how she wants
it to be right and it's like easy to say
yes to forever when you're so sure and
it's really a beautiful love song to her
fiance Orlando Bloom and I heard they
got married like they've been saying
that for years
no because amid baby buzz Katy Perry and
Orlando Bloom are planning a Japanese
wet
page successful on my god Katy Perry
getting married in Japan is so on brand
yes so I absolutely I've gotten my
journey on my sand hood for Katy Perry
has been about downs ups in rows like
ups and downs there were times when like
she was my number one over Kelly
Clarkson and then there were other times
where she was absolutely nothing of the
sort it had to do with her hair her hair
was her kryptonite yeah it was but also
her music and I feel as though we're
getting to a place like never really
over was a great song yeah at least in
Hawaii was not this is a really great
song I love her an American Idol she
seems so happy and just doing what she
wants to do even when it's not what I
like from her you're right but I I love
this face of her life for her I really
really do I think she's gonna be an
amazing mom but totally agree but it's
hard for me to like be so happy for her
just knowing like that the father of
this child like should be John Mayer and
I do feel like they are OTP they were so
in love they were so right for each
other and they just weren't right in the
moment and they always said that they
would come back to one another and they
did one time those paparazzi pictures of
them of them getting into the car in LA
but it didn't stick so while I'm happy
that her and Orlando Bloom have found
love I just know she gonna find a deeper
more meaningful love in John Mayer's bed
Wow I believe she might have found a
deeper more meaning for love in Josh
Groban's bed I don't think that that it
really is the one who got away and I
feel like for John Mayer everyone who's
ever dated like we [ __ ] like him and
Jessica Simpson know him and Taylor
sweat on him and Jennifer Aniston no I
don't I don't I had a little bit of me
like with Joe if him and Taylor should
have got together but I don't really
think that's a realistic love like I
think that his relationship with Katie
with Katy Perry was the most mature
relationship he's ever been I mean that
photo of them at the Grammys with her
and the green seafoam dress and him in
the blue velvet suit like I will never
forget the most iconic photo ever taken
and I think about it all the time and I
think about her boobs all the time
because they were so perfect
but I don't I mean I just had shipped
John Mayer with me but I don't really
ship him with all of his girlfriends or
all the girls like that we think he's
dating because I think that for most of
them they were pretty toxic but
something about the Katy Perry
relationship for me was different they
had that song together who you love and
then I saw him at Barclays Center and
the music video came out that day and I
turned to man I said Ben I'm telling you
Katy Perry's gonna be at this concert lo
and behold who came out at the end of
the concert Katy Perry that song sucks
I happen to agree it doesn't suck but I
have like our super high bar for John
Mayer songs because she's for Katy Perry
songs well not recently but she's a
tyrant songwriter yeah and I thought
that it would be so I thought it would
be everything of the sort and it wasn't
nothing of the sort
it just wasn't everything of the sort I
totally agree yeah that song is just not
but the music video is cute yeah no I I
have a ship it's still at the port
because of Colonel virus because the
people can't get off they're being
quarantined but Katy Perry and Orlando
Bloom are on it it's cute I mean
obviously when I think of Orlando Bloom
what do you think of most people think
of Lord of the Rings or whatever he was
in Pirates of the Caribbean oh I think
of the Orlando Bloom's what's up Amy
Schumer's favorite sports team and
trainwreck oh no I think of those
paparazzi pictures of him paddling bored
naked and like the South of France I
also think the security camera pictures
of him making out with Selena Gomez on
the curb okay cigarette and also like
innovating cat at a club when he was
like supposed to be dating Katy Perry
yeah and then I also think about like
the drama with him in Miranda Kerr when
like people said Miranda Kerr had sex
with Justin Bieber and like cheated on
Orlando Bloom with Justin Bieber and
then I also sometimes think about Kate
Bosworth why weren't they together oh
maybe I don't know that was like before
am I like Stan hood for pop culture I
was like just say we're in a movie
together possible I don't know I can't
keep up and it's weird I don't really
know anything about Orlando because we
never saw the franchise of movies that
he's in and I want to say it's Lord of
the Rings but it might also be Pirates
of the Caribbean pirates of the
Caribbean Johnny Depp hurts man yeah
yeah so I think it's Lord of the Rings
Ben is like obsessed with Lord of the
Rings but it's weird to like know so
much about Orlando Bloom but I don't
think I've ever seen anything that he's
ever been in yeah and took the words
right out of my mouth when we were
growing up it was like it's like the way
people think about Justin Bieber like
heartthrob her dad like loved him would
love to marry him the girls throwing
themselves at him and I just like can't
even relate yeah I just like wasn't
around for those conversations because
we never saw Lord of the Rings maybe it
was the Narnia movies definitely
something super no attorney is something
supernatural no not at all
The Lion the Witch in the Wardrobe okay
next story coronavirus continues to take
the world by storm and now the
entertainment segment in the shirt
industry is making some changes first of
all you know Ultra Music Festival in
Miami has been postponed and we'll
probably definitely be cancelled then no
time to die release date for the new
James Bond movie
is moving to fall in the hopes that a
global theater biz will be back at full
strength by then the people are really
taking precautionary measures for their
business it's weird how like businesses
either thrive or like are affected
negatively or positively by global
moments you know likes like the Purell
business has never been better but the
music and I mean the film industry I
guess it's a global thing so it's
definitely suffering yeah it's gonna
suffer it was supposed to come out on
April 10th but now it's gonna come out
on November 25th that's a really far
step and I mean there's tons of other
movies that would be coming out I wonder
if they're gonna follow suit yeah this
is so weird yeah very very crazy this is
just not what you think about when you
think of like a global pandemic virus no
but it's something that you should think
about I think what a lot of people are
thinking about now too is Coachella
mm-hmm and stagecoach breeding ground
for many diseases yeah even though it's
kind of far out and we'll see how things
go I feel like they could be canceled I
feel like that too and I honestly
wouldn't be mad if Coachella was
canceled because I feel a lot of
pressure to go to Coachella even though
I don't want to I would be devastated if
stagecoach was canceled because it is
the best weekend of the year but then
I'm actually this apart this piece
that's not adding up for me where it's
like people are saying that in the
spring summer the virus will die down
but there izing that definitely they're
saying it like hopefully right but
they're saying like we can expect that
that's a silver lining that come spring
summer like the virus will go away and
that's why we can still have the
Olympics can I tell you that by that
Tom's you're the only person I've heard
that from really yeah I've been hearing
it everywhere oh it's hot as hell oh
that's true
yeah so which one is it to me they'll
just like the heat seems like it would
be such a more toxic way to spread it's
like the heat is so gross and every was
like breathing and sweating to me it's
like so much more of like a transfer of
bodily fluids I feel like it would
thrive in a warm weather yeah but I get
that it's a flu but like people still
got the flu in the spring yeah a little
more corona related changes oh and by
the way with people's allergies like
sniffling all over it's worse I'm
telling you kuranes not gonna die in the
spring yeah we'll see and we'll you know
let you know about camp toast but we'll
kind of follow whatever everybody yeah I
know there's no stagecoach you'll
probably be no cam toes by the way if
literally coronavirus impacts camp toast
I will be so [ __ ] upset like let's
just make everywhere
man suits yeah that would be fun yeah
we'll see well we're not making any
decisions yeah but I mean this is
obviously bigger than camp toast I said
them no I just I felt like I had to say
that I did but you also can't get your
own mug fill that Starbucks anymore
because of coronavirus I think they
never should have done that in the first
place because it's [ __ ] disgusting
now that we were putting this on the
stand now that were putting it in
perspective of like hygiene
yeah because it was a nice thing for
sustainability but that also was like
[ __ ] disgusting no and I'm 100% I
didn't even know that people did that
because I don't drink at Starbucks but
the fact that that ever was a thing is
not shocking to me that now that there's
a global virus going around because
we're all sharing mugs yeah not cool
disgusting oh my god okay next story
some hills drama but I usually wouldn't
care but I love Mischa Barton is this
her Instagram post yes Mischa Barton
bash is reported the hills replacement
Caroline d'amour so Us Weekly reported
that the hills new beginnings Mischa
Barton is out Caroline damn Maury is in
today said it was because the former OC
star was quote too boring Barton Andrew
Barton shared a screenshot of the Us
Weekly headline in question on Instagram
with the caption lol where do people get
their reporting farm she went on to take
digs at dumb or a CEO of pizza girl Inc
a radio host on - radio and producer of
vimeos DJ Diaries never heard of any of
those projects but could for her me she
said as if anyone would watch Caroline
diem or try to hock her boring ass pasta
bowls and greasy pizza on TV stop that
right now
she tried that it was like watching
paint try get the story straight first
Us Weekly so is she saying that none of
this was true or that it's not she
wasn't fired because she was too boring
which part of this is untrue I hope the
fact that she's not coming back as the
untrue part because I absolutely loved
her oh my hell I hope that the part of
this girl being on the show was also not
true because I'm not trying to cast
anyone who has beef with Mischa Barton
like to me Mischa Barton was the most
interesting part of that whole show she
was so precious and we just like stand
her come back so anyone who's gonna
throw a wrench in that come back it's
not welcome on the show in my opinion
yeah especially if it's someone who who
I don't know in any regard like right
like even
listing of her accolades as impressive
as they might be I'm still unfamiliar
I've not heard of one of those things
Mischa Barton obviously was a new cast
member but we know who she is and then
also Brandon Lee was another new cameras
parents to me that's interesting to me
that's interesting and he was really
great she definitely didn't open up a
lot on the show like we never even
really saw her house or anything yeah
but I feel like she was getting there
season two is for people who have been
on tality TV for 10 plus years to be at
the same level as Mischa Barton who's
just like getting her feet wet she
honestly reminds me of a very similar
like arc to Denise Richards who kind of
lived very publicly had some scandal and
ended up on reality TV and in the first
season like did really well and then I
think what happens I'm not sure in the
next season of Beverly Hills is that
Denise
opens up even more and it ends up like
biting her in the ass yeah and they're
saying she's not gonna go to the reunion
which is like a trend now these days
that Lisa Vanderpump well actually
Adrienne Maloof started but it's it
shouldn't be allowed no it should not be
allowed I mean it is in their contracts
and that's all that they can do but
these the show makes these women so rich
that they don't care about breaching
their contract yeah some of the women
not all of them yeah
anyways I think Misha not being on the
show will be a very big loss I think
that she added a layer that at first I
was not open to I was like I don't need
traditional celebrities on my reality TV
programs yeah and then I was completely
changed yeah and I think that her
Instagram post pretty much confirmed
that she's not she's moving leaving the
show I think I don't know I think okay
we'll see next
I do wish she would have been more clear
really exciting news so clueless pop-up
restaurant is opening in Los Angeles for
the film's 25th anniversary
what another reason why we've got to get
to LA in celebration the restaurant is
like iconic in clueless no but it's a
clueless themed restaurant so in
celebration of the iconic teen movies
25th anniversary Paramount Pictures has
teamed up with the masterminds behind
past pop-ups saved by the max the Peach
Pit and the Breaking Bad experience to
create as if a limited run dining
experience that's sure to have the
Baldwin's and Betty's totally bug in
wait I'm dead but to me this seems so
strange to have a restaurant because at
least with the Peach Pit and the saved
by the max like they recreated the diner
and the club like if they're gonna do
clueless they should like recreate
her house or somebody though her closet
cafeteria and maybe somewhere where
people can go it's not just a museum
it's like a consumer experience yeah you
know I get that but like to me
restaurant is just not synonymous with
clueless like so many other things like
her closet like you should be able to
shop like a pop-up shop yeah but I think
like people want to go to like it's
teachers and it'll be 90s theme but it's
even like the Britney Spears thing it's
not like a restaurant it's a full
experience and like people are loving it
yes but Britney Spears like whole life
is worthy of a museum animal career but
I think a restaurant for clueless is
perfect everyone will dress up and
they'll make it so totally fabulous as
if by Theodora by Dora do you have a
name for the restaurant or called as if
oh he farted on his way boy we make a
fart on the ng bad boy makeup hard times
you want to live with mom wow that was
like so hurtful he came he saw he farted
disgusting but I loved him nonetheless
get up come on good boy
yo man little man's okay ready for our
fifth and final story this one goes out
to the Tipsy toasters out there who
deserve this more than anyone I'm their
president let's go white claw has added
three new fan demanded flavors and
demanded demanded a fan demanded flavor
which are the best kind of place so true
the demands are so demanding new flavors
are lemon watermelon and tangerine
by the way lemon very interesting
because it's a vodka drink so it's like
a lemon martini what was the next one
watermelon people love watermelon in
their cocktails I don't really live for
like watermelon juice I loved watermelon
I like anything I like watermelon gum
and like watermelon slices but I don't
live for watermelon like flavored items
ooh damn what was a third one can Doreen
not my vibe again I also don't drink
white cloth so I don't know if I'm
necessarily like the one to be spitting
facts but they need a white clot aquila
ah yeah like a hard tequila Seltzer that
actually sounds like kind of gross I
know but there's so many hard like
alkane beverages for vodka there's white
cloud there's Bunning viv there's like
all these different sparkling Seltzer's
but I would like a sparkling seltzer
that's a tequila base that's next but
why zoom just came out with sparkling so
someone's working
I wish they would do a flavor that's
cucumbers flavored I feel like oh yeah
threshing call it a Tom Collins or
Jackie Oh a Jackie Oh that's what they
should call them when you took a
bartending class is the best money I
ever spent
I can still whip up a fabulous drink
like with a fabulous what a fabulous
drink with minimal ingredients it's just
like oh we don't realize the importance
of ice muddling shaking the [ __ ]
drink and you can make something that
would otherwise be sad I'm sorry mildly
delicious I said remember when you took
a bartending class and then you also won
the competition at the end of the class
yes at the end of the class the
classmates were asked to the classmates
yes to make a cocktail of their own
choice using the skills that we had just
learned and then the judges were gonna
judge it and my cocktail one it was
called the Jackie O that was the
funniest thing that you ended up winning
I know like hilarious by myself which is
just like the bravery it's an adult it's
hard it is hard but I'm so glad that I
did it you guys feel like people should
be more stuff like that
I'm tweet recap Real Housewives of New
Jersey before we bring out TL Jane I'm
okay real houses in New Jersey had their
first reunion episode last night again
wasn't living for the looks but I loved
that the set was paying homage to the
first reunion which is now 10 years ago
Teresa has been on the couch for 10
years she really is one of the remaining
oh geez now that Vicki's gone Kyle
Richards is an OG mm-hmm
Teresa Ramona Ramona and nene leakes is
but she did like briefly go away when
she thought she was too good for
housewives because she was yeah um so do
they count her as an OG maybe cuz they
need more oh geez right but then you
would have to count LuAnn who had one
season as a friend
oh you can't you should have LuAnn more
than you count meanie yeah because Nene
like moved to LA yeah okay I mean who
could blame her because we love LA so
the reunion there's three parts part
what is always like kind of boring
because really they save the good stuff
for two and three right so we addressed
like the little little dubbing things
but Jennifer just came out like swinging
from the get-go hazing for no reason
like before teen son wants everyone to
dislike her and right now only Teresa is
her friend it seems like even Dolores
has kind of done with her I know but you
know what like I've always fancied
Dolores as the real moral compass of the
show um and she's just nothing of the
sort these days because she's so blinded
by her loyalty to Teresa that it's
actually so frustrating um so I no
longer really give like her that respect
of being
like the honest one and like the loyal
like because she she throws reason out
the window and when it comes to Jennifer
she calls her out a little bit but she's
so firm on her side like on her couch
that she doesn't speak rationally and I
feel like she used to just say what she
thought because it was what she believes
not because she had like alliances yeah
to me the voices of reason on the show
like actual reason not like reality TV
reason and those sorts of politics are
Jackie and Margaret agree they are
rational people who like if you were in
their situations you would have their
reaction maybe as a viewer watching it
their reactions aren't always the most
entertaining they're a little too
sensitive but like they are saying what
it is yeah it was just really
frustrating
I feel like this particular cast of
Jersey is like really devoid of a lot of
logic in their arguments and they just
they just side with people because it's
the side that they're on not because
they think it's the right thing to do or
say and that's really frustrating to
watch yeah and I just feel like Jennifer
is it's like she doesn't want to be on
the show anymore because she's not even
trying to salvage some of these
relationships whereas sometimes like you
fight with someone on the show you get
into it at the reunion but you come to
the conclusion of I'm sorry that I hurt
your feelings I didn't mean it in that
way I didn't think before I spoke and it
came out worse than I had wanted it to I
apologize but she's just digging in and
doubling down and I just don't
understand that I think I have an
explanation actually I think that she
thinks the key to success on this show
is not to be outrageous yes you have to
be irate just on the show to be
successful but you also have to maintain
a relationship in the group because if
you're irrelevant to the group and
everyone hates you it doesn't make sense
anymore and you could still be really
entertaining and exciting but if the
group hates you
that's that she doesn't realize that
part she just sings like I want to be
outrageous and people like gift me and
like make fun of me and she thinks
that's the key to success but she's
forgetting the other 50% it's like yes
you have to be interesting but you also
have to be a key member of the group and
sometimes you get so focused on being so
crazy that you isolate yourself from the
group and that renders you irrelevant
yeah I think she's forgetting I think
the fact that like Jennifer can call
Melissa too self-absorbed have a child
which is so deeply a conversation and
then Teresa yep that's her opinion just
has her mouth shut whereas if some when
Jackie anytime Jackie went in on Teresa
and by the way with like every single
you know fiber of her being and it very
so their statements and Teresa was upset
at Melissa for not having her back and
just the double standard between the two
of them it's it's insane no it's crazy
when literally Jennifer was saying the
most evil things about Melissa and her
journey to fertility how it's like a
fake storyline and and II said Teresa
how do you feel about your friend saying
the stuff about your sister-in-law she
goes I mean that's her opinion right so
he's saying if you could show your
husband would he be in jail that's her
opinion it was so crazy just to see like
how bad of a friend and sister-in-law
Teresa is and how Melissa just doesn't
say anything cuz we're in this cycle now
where it's like you really you you get
so frustrated because like the worlds
don't apply to Therese and then you see
this footage of her going through the
most horrible things and like you just
forget yeah but it's so it must be so
frustrating to even attempt to be a
friend of hers yeah but also for Melissa
it's like not even about the show and
having t no respect Teresa it's just
like she doesn't want problems with her
family I'm sure that time in her life
when her husband and her sister-in-law
are fighting and it's like causing all
this drama and the cousins like she does
not miss that and so if it means her
swelling of her pride and just like
thinking what she thinks I'm not saying
it she will do that can I just give like
a round of applause to Margot Joseph's
for two seasons in a row being seated
next to Andy as a relatively new
housewife on the couch
I think that's admirable yeah marge was
everything everything apart with her
halter some of the standout moments to
me I really as much as and I still love
Jennifer like as a person but when she's
not being self aware it's frustrating
but I absolutely love that she shared
the story of her brother and her mom and
watching the package of it just the
highlight reel
I had full-body chills same I feel like
she could have easily hid that it was
like a little you know it's a
controversial subject and she's like
putting her own family on blast and not
in a positive way and I think she it
would have been easier for her not to
show any of this and just like pretend
like that part of her life doesn't exist
but I thought it was an really bold and
interesting and good choice of her to be
so vocal about it like in the first
episode yes and I feel that way about
Jackie sharing more about her eating
disorder because we've known about it
since her first season but this season
she really gets into some of the more
specific and those pictures from her
wedding were heartbreaking oh my god so
crazy it's like sometimes you think one
picture like whatever it's a bad angle
but no they were multiple ones and they
were really really sad yeah it was
really sad but she I do think that she's
a really great
role model and she takes that really
seriously in how she eats on the show
yeah because she knows that people are
watching her and not in a judgmental way
but in you know other people might be
going through away to me like the most
relatable and honest friendship is the
friendship between Jackie and Margaret
because even Margaret like had something
to say about Jackie's eating and not
Anna give away Margot was just like
maybe she doesn't think about food at a
kid's party like for me throwing a party
all I can think about is food because I
love to eat and I felt the same way
about Margaret but once it was explained
to her by Jackie how like saying stuff
like that is not okay because of what
she went there and she like very openly
Illustrated exactly what you're I
through Margaret never said anything
about it again like to me that's a real
[ __ ] friendship like no one's perfect
you make mistakes you've learned from
someone you listen to them and you move
on and you don't do it again
yeah that's like a lost concept on
housewives in general and especially on
the season of Jersey yeah another
conversation that was really frustrating
was the michael conversation David sorry
David who's Michael that's what you
think his name is
Oh David how did you know who I was we
had a conversation a few weeks ago where
we called him Michael the entire time
and then someone told me that that's not
his name we did yeah oh my god we're out
of control I mean it just goes to show
like how he doesn't show up we don't
even know his name and I agreed that she
like has a has a leg to stand on when it
comes to the conversation of him not
showing up anywhere like he's going to
shooting school when he can barely show
up to an event that's important to her
and that's like a relationship problem
that they should figure out but I just
think all the women saying that he they
should that she should move on from him
was so drastic because I don't know
they're all putting so much emphasis on
this ring in the engagement when I don't
feel like it's of really any importance
no not at all she's happy and she's
having a good time she's a nice house
who cares she has her own house she has
Frank she has she has her kids like she
has what she needs out of life if
David's like a good time for her then
that's all I need sure well why she is
like wants to get married so like a 22
year old at giving someone an ultimatum
and it's like you have kids what like of
course in benighted scary but you don't
need to yeah I don't agree with that
whole thing and I feel like David's a
nice guy he works too much and that's
not a bad thing but that's something
they definitely can and should think
about like that's how Dolores used to
feel about him where it's like listen
I'm happy like until I'm not happy then
I'll I'll give him the boot right she's
not happy like she's like influenced by
everyone else now
who are like oh you need to be engaged
you need to be engage and now she's
upset she's not engaged and it's like
you don't need yes she let everyone get
to hurry you're right yeah like her
parents everything yeah when she said
that she her and Frank are never gonna
end up together that really broke my
heart it really really broke my heart um
okay so we're gonna get the lady game
because they just arrived so take a
break before we bring them out I just
also wanted to let everyone know that
our segment with a lady gang is brought
to you by Charlotte Tilbury Charlotte
Tilbury is one of the most highly
regarded and influential celebrity
makeup artists of all time
she's a groundbreaking female
entrepreneur and founder of her
eponymous company Charlotte Tilbury
beauty with 27 years in the beauty
industry she's been responsible for the
creation of countless iconic styles and
is regarded as a visionary and
trendsetter in 2013 she forever changed
the face of a global beauty industry
with the launch of her makeup line and
skincare collection I use the magic
cream it's amazing decoding her
traditionally closed-door VIP expertise
giving women and men the tools to be the
most beautiful versions of themselves
Charlotte believes that everyone at
every age deserves to look and feel the
most beautiful version of themselves
every day through the power of makeup
her client list is very extensive with
hundreds of iconic Beauty styles for
high-profile models actresses
celebrities and luminaries like Kate
Moss Amal Clooney Jennifer Aniston Kim
kardashian-west ever heard of her
Jennifer Lopez Miranda Kerr we were just
talking about her Victoria Beckham JK
Rowling Sofia Vergara Salma Hayek
Penelope Cruz there's the list goes on
and there pillow talk collection is
Charlotte's best-selling globally adored
nude pink shade that's on everyone's
lips it's a little black dress of makeup
versatile and dreamy the perfect pink
nude shade to bring out the most
beautiful version of you the proof is in
the numbers America loves pillow talk in
2019 it was the number one lipstick in
the u.s. of 2019 and new as of January
16th is that they are now carrying more
pillow talk shades to love Charlotte is
expanding her iconic pillow talk
collection to include medium and intense
shades of each cult pillow talk product
so there's a lip liner a lipstick a
blusher and an eye palette the adored
iconic shade is now available to flatter
everyone's natural beauty and can also
be used to dial up your look for every
mood from day to desk to date and beyond
Charlotte Tilbury is shoppable directly
from Charlotte Tilbury calm that's CH AR
l OT te TI l bu ry calm as well as their
freestanding beauty wonderland and the
grove in LA
they're also sold at most Nordstrom
north
from and Sephora's in North America
visit Charlotte Tilbury com4 store
finder I've been using Charlotte Tilbury
for years it's similar to a beautiful
makeup the morning walk collection is
everything of the sort it's literally
all I use on my lips right now and now
they have more shades more products like
literally from this lipstick that took
the world by storm as it should have
stormy Webster I'm sorry we will be
right back with the lady gang so stay
tuned drop a question in the YouTube
stream go get a snack and we'll see you
in a minute
okay we are back with podcast hosts TV
hosts and now soon-to-be New York Times
bestselling authors the lady gang Becca
Jack LT hello we have had you guys on
the show separately yes and now together
yes you broke your ankle leaving our
show we're so sorry yes we're really
sorry supposed to be but it was dead
anyway yeah are you healed I'm healed
but like her bones are made of dust
right yeah honestly I should I don't
know why dressed up so much like I feel
looked fabulous
I felt so much pressure being in the
room with you jack is your phone okay
thank you I feel treasurer being in the
room with you you guys like I got a
dress up and I wore a Louboutin to the
morning toast you look so fabulous
yeah you did I hope it was wearing a
jumpsuit right it was fabulous who's
worth it you wore a cast for how long
like I well I had to wear it longer
because of course I walked around on it
right days before I realized it was
broken right eight weeks
exciting but honestly it was my best
Instagram content it was because people
felt sorry for me in a way that I always
want that attention but I can't just ask
for it when I'm healed right you liked
it if that's like video Londa Hadid Lyme
disease I was like there is a term for a
viewer where you use it for for
attention
yeah like hypochondria as well that's
like what you have are you focusing
about like if you're a hypochondriac are
you posting about your illnesses like
she I'm not a hypochondriac
[Laughter]
well just think of the press you would
get if you did get right you think I did
we need to talk about tick-tock
you three are all on tick-tock now heck
are you on begrudgingly okay you're it's
you're it's it's new it's it's always
tough to you know get on a new platform
you don't know what the trends are
especially now okay so what do you what
is your strategy when it comes to the
lady gang on tick-tock it brings out a
thirstiness and people that you didn't
know yeah not everyone should be dancing
to their phones yeah yeah there are just
some people that shouldn't be sexually
dancing yeah I would agree but you know
Becca you were on Glee so like you've
seen yourself dance many times in like a
highly produced good-quality
type thing Keltie you were a Rockette
you obviously know what you look like
dancing for us regular people I always
thought it was a good dancer like I
actually thought I was like pretty Bob
until I really take talk of me dancing
and I was nothing of the sort
see I know I'm a terrible dancer but
since they are dancers they pull me into
these hopes he pulls me into these
tick-tocks if the first one that you
wanted to do was like a full-on like
booty pop roll dance some hottie is
doing those yeah they compared me to
James Charles and I'm like my it hurt in
her it's really her baby either James
Charles I'm gonna take it in stride but
it definitely took my confidence down
and like clawed really I thought it was
a good dancer and you guys are actually
professional dancers but I was trying to
learn cannibal yesterday and we did I
was so embarrassed by the way that I
looked doing it it's like it's not that
complex it's just like but something's
wrong when you can't pop yeah you are a
good dancer oh my god thank you so much
for saying that my confidence is so
blown from this app because and also
like I don't wear crop tops which is why
I'm like failing at the shine
yeah it's cross-browser my brand so I'm
like I just need to get one on it's
totally for you yeah it's totally I'm
not sure of you know actually you do
know cuz I just asked you this before we
started filming but pretend like I
didn't um you are a part of a tick-tock
that went pretty viral last night
I shot on my fur you page it had over
500 thousand likes I think almost a
million views because you had all the
tick tock kids on Entertainment Tonight
let's talk about it Oh God the [ __ ]
hi sorry it took a scary sound that hype
house so on Entertainment Tonight
they are EP Aaron who is Brad loves tick
tock
so we're ahead of the trends we're like
let's bring she's like my good times and
I was like okay cuz normally we talked
to George Clooney like right you sure
you want like the hype house kids so we
brought them on stage and it was like it
was like trying to bring together a
group of like meatballs like at an
Italian feast they were like some we're
just standing there gays like it was
like my brain just I was like what is
happening so first of all these are all
people that have never had jobs right so
one were like 16 right so we're like I
had a job when I was 16 anyway so I'm
like okay everyone stand here and we're
gonna do this thing and the directors
like we're gonna do this thing in
essence like wait wait wait she's never
like crop-top
like I can't dude that's not nowhere
shine of the hype house kids showed up
to the Entertainment Tonight set with a
shirt that said [ __ ] oh my god do you
not know what television is shirt on
television so we're like we got to
change him and then Addison is like I
mean it was these kids couldn't be
bothered being an entertainer oh yeah
and he's like I have a hard out I have a
hard out when I used to have to sing it
like old folks home yes back no respect
and by the way cuts us room like a paper
bag kind of worst outfit that's what I
think is so funny about it is that like
they were like hey we're having some
like tik-tok kids you should wear pants
tomorrow and I was like okay well I have
three pairs of pants and they're all
businesswomen
like I actually thought you looked
fabulous like I saw the video last night
I'm like she looks fabulous like it's
the whole dancing as weird but you you
yourself look fabulous and that's all
that I haven't seen the video now I'm so
excited I was I was so surprised it was
like okay as
we were doing this right we're doing an
interview and just imagine that in the
middle of this live show you I'm Addison
and I just went no the light is so good
here we have to talk
she just stood up and she was like mom
hold my phone and she just like took 15
minutes to make a tick-tock and I was
like we're trying to make a television
show like you know did you stop down
production she taught you a dance she
taught us they made like an
Entertainment Tonight tick-tock dance
okay that's very good marketing and the
one yeah is there something and I mean
this would love as a new talker that's a
lot loving the platform a new talker I
was like did she say well so a lot of
stuff is always being taken down like
because because it's borderline
inappropriate to a point where it's like
it might be a felony maybe yeah it's so
weird but you know who's watching these
videos like probably 14 and her dance
was like and she was just like bouncing
her boobs and then like rolling and oh
my god like I know I was also doing that
to a pillow right like Jerry Romeo and
Juliet Leonardo DiCaprio like trying to
masturbate for the first time yeah it's
weird I think these kids will live to
regret some of the things they're
posting yeah and so will I already Jim I
can't even look at my own tape time I
dress he takes out my I should believe
that yeah I just think that until the
day I die ya know one day I'll just
delete my whole thing but for now I'm
having a good time yeah you telling me
um okay you guys let's talk about your
book you wrote a book it's coming out
June 2nd but it's available for
pre-order on Amazon yes
can you are books or Souls oh right
that's what they say anywhere books are
sold
can you tell me it logistically what
it's like to write a book with readable
global okay so we started off the very
first thing that we did for the book is
we just sat and talked like this
and Kelsey wrote down a bunch of
questions I'm pre planned for weeks
yes Porter you produced it but we're
like okay we're gonna talk about
breakups and then we kind of like went
down the line of what our lady getting
advice would be for breakups and then
got it transcribed Kelsey went through
it not that great and then we like
really refine the words that we were
talking about yeah that's like the lady
game voice yes right oh right because
it's a combination right it's a
combination of all the three things that
we sort of agree on because there's
nothing more scary than when somebody's
like right 300 words and my page yeah
yeah you know I really never realized
until seeing you three all together like
how different you are and I'm sure like
that that's why people like in the
audience really relate to you guys
everyone feels like they're like a jack
or a Kelsey and I'm sitting here and I'm
I think I'm totally a Kelty all right
right I really feel like I'm a
combination of all three because I used
to at first glance I was a Kelty because
I'm like super organized and Taipei but
then when we did your guys a show I was
like oh no I'm definitely a jock because
I'm pretty chill and and calm but then I
was reading the book and I was like no I
am a Beca because I try so hard to be
perfect but I won't let anyone know how
hard I'm trying and then I just want to
be like oh yeah actually I think you're
about just said it I'm just like this
yeah yeah I ended up on a Beckett but I
think the fact that people can relate to
so many different parts of you guys is
what it is and I did get a chance to
read the book and it is so so good and
so funny I at one point had tears in my
eyes for mouthing and that's the best
kind of book would you say it's fabulous
I would say it's fabulous
all right that's a big deal five stars
on Goodreads for sure guys redesigned
the cover I want to take away the part
rinses late again cause I know fabulous
oh yes like on the back where you have
no nails I feel like you guys are so
busy like individually but then also as
the lady gang how do you might manage
jib planners use Google Calendar we
counted shared calendar company credible
like employee named Alex who like
literally runs are alive hmm
and Kelty works ten times harder than
either of us that's not true actually
that was maybe possibly true the first
two and a half years of lady gang but I
do want to say that since the brain
has become a big brand like Jack
designed that cover
I can't woman yeah yeah like at the
inside of the book like she really like
went through and Becca was like we've
really all stepped up yeah so I want to
like break Janis well press to this yeah
brick so we don't need it to the
marathon's all right what's the font
here I love it cabernet oh of course
it's so chic I really like Ang's yeah
like I would use it in a poster oh we
had a question for you because you guys
record podcasts all the time and you
just had nene leakes on your podcast who
was obviously very iconic and most
people don't attribute her biggest
moment it's what we attributed is to
being Roz Washington on Glee and they
want to know like what was that like for
you was it a homecoming of sorts Becca
well to be honest we only shot maybe a
day or two on the same like together
yeah there's a scene and like the scene
that we shot together was like at the
football field and Long Beach at the
high school that we shot at and she was
like supposed to be like dancing and
doing like some hype thing hmm I
basically just like watched her being
like a dancing puppet all day exciting
and I don't honestly know if she made
the connection that we had no idea the
podcast just came out and I think she
still doesn't know you were on Glee you
know something in common glee and she
was like oh this is gonna be a reunion
and I kept telling everyone like she
doesn't remember me like I know that she
doesn't and granted she shouldn't I was
like the 85th cast member to join that
show in Detroit with the most important
right that is devastating to hear like
truly I'm so upset that we were gonna
get a better answer out of that I mean
yeah it's kind of great it's I wouldn't
expect anything else it's so raw so
rosin it's so Meany yes I guess she
wasn't watching the show you know and
also you have a clip podcast I mean I'm
sorry I know we talked we you guys are
so accomplished but I will always just
end up talking about clay because it's
such a I'm watching right now it's such
like an important part of my life and
I'm up to the really [ __ ] up part
where your character gives another girl
an eating disorder it's like who the
[ __ ] thought of that incredibly [ __ ]
up storyline it's it's really painful to
watch and that some of that [ __ ] could
never fly also shoutout
- Melissa Benoist oh she's frightening
oh I did see that um and she used to be
married to someone else from Glee right
yeah but it was not okay actively
[Music]
network you have ugly metaphorically
podcast but Jenna and Kevin it is they
do the Glee cap now Oh today yeah so
they basically go through every single
episode and they bring on someone who
was on it or worked on it and they talk
about the entire episode so if you start
over I mean I do a long time the pilot
sees a bike Leah Leah came on and talked
about the pilot with them and then they
had Harry Shum come on and talk about
some other episode watch some other
shows they're being honest with you I
did not watch clean and it joined Jude
like how special it was just yesterday
he loves the female energy what in the
room market for him to be doing yes Theo
actually spent so much time he's boy
obviously technically but Theo spends so
much time around female energy that he
pees like a girl it's actually very
sweet yes like a lady they can expect in
the book there's tons of short stories I
mean we give a lot of questionable
advice um there's a lot of embarrassing
stories and I think the point of us
writing the book is to help make other
women feel more normal about all the
weird [ __ ] that they do yeah um yeah and
sometimes there's parts of our lives
like you know when you're making a
podcast where you just go to the you
kind of always go to the funny and you
go to the like what's going on in pop
culture and that stuff and write some
stories about us and how we became who
we are as human beings that sort of fit
better as essays in the book yeah and
like one of my very first books that I
loved was Chelsea Handler's my
horizontal line - I was like I remember
reading that and being like oh my gosh
like no one's ever talked about like
being a ho right and I was like I'm free
I think that's kind of one of the things
that we took into our book is like these
little essays where we just really
wanted to like show people like these
your deep darkest secrets and so there's
things don't make you laugh I'm really
proud of it yes Barry and I think every
complet legend I heard you were but
maybe you're not that was like when
Rosie called out Clay Aiken who's Rosie
reading the ladies who punch in my whole
life revolves around is it good
you guys I know we're here to talk about
our book the ladies who punch is the
best book really ever I don't know whose
eyes are but I don't know if it's
because like I was living in New York at
the start of the view I lived next door
to the studio so like I don't know if
it's that exciting to anyone else for me
but it's so [ __ ] good but if you
don't watch the view would you still I
guess okay fascinating for any women who
are starting up anything in
entertainment hearing about Barbara
Walters she is a evil genius like that
you're gonna say like an evil [ __ ] well
I mean somebody might raise a genius
she's the Kelty like oh wow the way this
is and why we don't do our podcast life
yeah that's why I'm Mykelti Joe
something that happened to me I can't
even be mad 100 yeah it's great for
presale orders so Becca when you were
doing press did you ever go on the view
no no like the scariest place yeah it
would be my verified and I would be way
too scared but nobody told me that if I
started loving Donald Trump that I could
probably get a job on the view range
well yeah cuz there's a minimum of women
willing to know my TV to talk about it
yeah yeah the next act yeah yeah I mean
someone like brainwash me I'm sure yeah
yeah where dollar signs to pretend to
love Donald Trump and yeah and be on the
beat and that every Servet avoid ah no
no no I don't think I would ever go on
the view like when we were canceled he
actually got offered to go on to you
yeah back to like tell your story yeah
just like they were just being thirsty
like for what was going on in the news
that day and that was uh
and I ignored the email but I actually
wrote back like a month ago - we
actually just celebrated anniversary
what you do we just cried and my ignore
my time hop like I just can't look at my
time up that day but it's also the day I
got engaged so it's a youngin yeah we're
in the same year yeah weird like woke up
dude engagement happen first no but my
husband was planning it all day he had
no clue what was happening to it like
the media and so I text him wait like
usually I would that's something I would
have told him and I got home I just
didn't want him to see it somewhere else
so I was like hey babe like my family's
in the media today I just want to let
you know he's like okay but he wasn't he
didn't even go to look at it because he
was planning an engagement I'm like his
whole family was in town like his
grandparents we couldn't not do it yeah
and we're like it's gonna be actually
right why I'm an employed notify I'm
exploiting the whole situation he's
actually was perfect weirdly enough it
was like it just in ones goes on life
goes on like all the material things are
gone sure but like what I have is
someone who'll stand by me no matter
what and that's important it was really
um beautiful yeah it was bittersweet it
was nice and it was also like a high and
a low together it was it it was a bad
[Applause]
[Laughter]
your podcast after this so if you're
looking for more lady gang morning shows
crossover check it out the book is
available for pre-order anywhere you can
find books it's called act like a lady
and it's actually very good I did read
even though everyone knows I don't
really mean one specific story was very
funny no yeah yeah yeah growing up in
the Atlanta subdivision like I don't
even know what that is
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning show so millennium what are
you show me to live money to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
brought to us on YouTube please
something to subscribe this video thumbs
up
oh we're also available podcasting /
podcast movie facts that's about if I
action City Public Radio I heard me know
cashbox oh the places where ever you
choose to listen to podcast find us
Marni chose hi maybe subscribe five
stars leave a review about how beautiful
setting and smart we are we're back
tomorrow was Mike the situation and his
wife Lauren so check it out thank you
have an amazing day I'm gonna Celine
Dion concert tonight bye